let's make some goddamn hamburgers last
week I made some of the finest spaghetti
ever known to man but today we're making
goddamn hamburger hamburger now I never
done hamburgers before so hopefully this
will go okay
all right oh let's just start by getting
a pot I actually know how to make
hamburger okay I know you're gonna be
like all right I knew I know how to do
it and I'm gonna follow the recipe cuz
this time at least I know how to play
the game so I know what I'm doing okay
just add a little bit of olive oil and
the meat is in here right there it is
look at that beautiful burger meat and
burger put it in all right cook that
baby it's a hamburger soup you've never
had hamburgers soup let's double up from
the beef
oh wow yeah that looks good can we add a
third one my god it's a hamburger tower
can we get her oh that's cute
god damn it
oh let's have some cheese on it set some
hands with some milk all right this is
how you cook hamburger now we obviously
want to make some fries as well so just
grab your potatoes
Jake sex think I will like this bit so
just chop your taters just like that
this is a hard potato a very hard potato
doesn't want to get chopped whatever I
don't care all right so let's put these
in the fryer I think I have a fryer yeah
cool cool well most of them hint
so now let's oh cool all right
oh that's awesome he can fries that okay
let's check how the burgers doing oh
that looks maybe we need to add just a
hint of olive oil to cover all God the
cheese
why is the chief not melting dude all
right maybe that'll do all right let's
check on our golden boys are they
supposed to be black okay that looks
awesome is pathetic what else can you
fry I've always like wanted to
experiment with frying things like I
always wanted to fry my public in don't
get there we go and he scores
all right let's just let that simmer
baby all right I think our hamburgers
are done so let's just take this out
here and let's grab a plate I will
probably grab the biggest plate because
I don't want handle all right we got to
make it look good
how do I put it down there we go so
let's pour our a hamburger soup oh yeah
oh yeah that's what came up that cheese
looks so good
oh [ __ ] let's not forget about our price
okay they look good they're good how's
the pumpkin okay so we need to get the
hamburger bread so what you want to do
is you want to just put it on top of
here there you go
just cook it directly all right that's
cooked now let's put that down on the
plate how do I rotate it rotate okay
perfect put down goddamn it rotate put
down rotate put down all right let's
just throw it no oh you [ __ ] hamburger
how is that even possible
how do I put it down are you done yeah
it's done destruction hamburger bread
alright maybe grab a smaller flame dad
oh good trick okay
careful now we will put down very gently
put it down I need it to go upwards I
have an idea
we need the ogre the pumpkin that does
not look good I have more pressing
matters okay I got it
we need to that's fine five second
rule-- five second rule-- five second
rule-- five second rule-- there it is
okay put it down gently gently
are you fine I did it I did it I did it
I did it okay I don't know how I did it
but I did it now let's grab the burger
okay okay okay okay what the hell is
happening it's hovering
Game of the Year everyone move down
vertically you know I can't be bothered
getting another plate I can't even see
where you're going oh my god
[ __ ] I wanted the bread go Oh God
[Laughter]
we're gonna we're gonna drop it
move down vertically down vertically
move down vertically and then drop it
drop it drop it drop it oh my god that's
perfect okay we got this fam how's the
pumpkin pumpkins fine now all we have to
do all we have to do is get that burger
on top of oh my god I did it he's so
happy he's dancing I know we did decide
to double up okay why is it yellow why
does it look like that what is there is
that the cheat oh the cheese melted it
worked the cheddar cheese melted this is
gonna be delicious or is I literally
just press oh that's what I'm talking
about now let's get another hamburger
bread which you got to put it this one
we just got to put down on top all right
let's get the fries let's get the price
dude I'm a culinary genius
gently gently I mean that's good enough
for me huh that's good enough for me god
damn it it's seeping out I think I know
the trick now No aah
five-second rule no no
[Music]
alright good enough right now
I like cheese so I'm gonna get some
extra cheese on top how do we get the
pumpkin out of that spatula of course
that picks okay alright I know I'm not
supposed to do this cuz of how we win
last time but I really just want to melt
my cheese just a little bit oh god
what's happening
god damn blowtorch
I just wanna oh god no
they're still uppity you you did this
oh god no no no not again
god damn it I'm not my cooking book
saved the cooking book definitely door
is on fire why does this keep happening
to me
it does nothing
[Music]
all right so for dessert we're gonna
make pumpkin pie which is basically
pumpkin and lime juice that looks good
and then you want to fry it again
when you write a add a little bit of
extra power on it this is fine I've done
this before don't worry about it then
let's put that pumpkin down and there
you go there you have it I don't got oh
and there you have it everyone hamburger
with the pumpkin juice how is that still
on fire put it out oh you gave me how do
I put this out all right well that was
the hamburger pumpkin pie delicious oh I
got my throat's my throat's on fire see
you guys next week where we will make
PewDiePie hamburger what you never
played super simulator you know it's fun
right I'm not supposed to give my
opinion but give it a try and then you
can tell me if it's good or not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]